hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report hey did you know that on Sundays
at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time it's
locked down with the kaisers on our
Kaiser report Twitter periscope that's
right oh yeah
it's becoming the go-to Sunday show
Stacy max you might say it is dynomite
good times are guaranteed well in fact
you know what in our global economy a
monetary system right now good times are
promised in the economic system based on
JJ Powell at the printing press you know
this past week he went on 60 minutes and
he was saying oh you know we print money
digitally and there's no limit to the
amount of money we can print good times
for all that's right before there was
Didier jay-z or Kanye West there was JJ
Walker who was keeping it real in the
projects in Chicago with his famous tag
line dynomite and there was such a
strange rumor a few months ago that he
was dating Ann Coulter no they're very
good friends apparently and that's
according to his wikipedia but they are
not dating JJ Powell with the star of
good times his phrase was dynomite it
became super famous 74 to 79 we're in
similar time period now perhaps of
stagflation many people are calling for
stagflation a slowing economy and rising
prices for you know goods and services
so Jay Powell has promised to print
however and keep the good times rolling
no matter how bad things might be it's
gonna be good times one Banksy's fed
balance sheet hitting a hundred and
thirty trillion dollars if pal buys
everything this one bank is deutsche
bank and they see that the Fed could
possibly buy all outstanding equities
pawns everything and it would be a
hundred and thirty trillion dollars
right now their balance sheet is what
between seven and eight trillion you
heard it here first right I mean I've
been saying now for a few years that the
goal of the Federal Reserve Bank would
be to take the American economy private
that is to say it would buy all stocks
all bonds
property and now deutsche bank and other
banks are saying yeah they're gonna
print 130 trillion dollars they're not
gonna stop at six or seven trillion the
number of dollars are gonna print is
going to exceed the GDP of America by a
huge factor and they're gonna buy by
everything same with the other three or
four major central banks around the
world this is what neo feudalism looks
like okay if a few central banks print
hundreds of trillions and take
everything off the board and now they
own 99.99999% of all assets and everyone
else is living on a subsistence click
farm right click on an ad get a protein
pill in the casino gulag that's what
near feudalism is so now it's becoming
more of a accepted wisdom why we set it
on this show now for a few years so one
hundred and thirty trillion yes we did
say it quite a few years ago I think it
was 2011 when the Davos meeting happened
and they said they need a hundred and
trillion dollars they already told you
they they signaled it because they have
to signal it to the insiders because
they want the insiders to create a
citadel of absolute wealth whereby the
they never they promised each other
they've got each other's back so they
already told us it would be a hundred
trillion here you know Deutsche Bank is
saying that there's thirty eight point
five trillion in equities there's thirty
seven point eight trillion and
residential real estate so the
government already backstops a lot of
the residential real estate in America
but nevertheless they're gonna do that
so in this sort of project this grand
you know monetary project they there are
some winners and some losers the one
hundred and thirty trillion is also a
number which even mmm tears would admit
is the endgame as there will be nothing
left to nationalize or privatized
depending on one's view of who
ultimately owns the Federal Reserve this
is something you've said many times
about it being privatized right right so
nationalization of industries would be
socialism or communism and privatization
of these industries would be ultra
so-called capitalism but neo feudalism
is when you just take it all and we're
seeing this in the Koba 19 people are
prepping for neo whew
times and the casino gulag sheltering at
home
stuck online click on an ad get a
protein pill dynomite cuz more money is
going to be printed and if you've got a
multi-level marketing scheme you might
want to issue some junk bonds today cuz
the Fed jayjay pal has got your back ok
cuz Herbalife is looking to sell six
hundred million dollars worth of junk
bonds to finance share buybacks debt
that may yield about 8% the move is a
bit odd given the backdrop of economic
collapse and corporate desperation for
liquidity she had a whole bunch of
comments responding to this tweet of
hers about this Bloomberg article and
many pointed out that because JJ Powell
is there you know to provide good times
for all even a multi-level marketing
scheme like Herbalife well somebody
responded getting the Fed to buy your
stuff is the ultimate multi-level
marketing scheme well done so Herbalife
is a legal Ponzi scheme otherwise known
as a multi-level marketing scheme they
have always been dubious and always and
they're under a perpetual attack from
regulators around the world because
there there's a bit of a ponzi ask
scheme to their multi-level marketing
scheme and so to buy back their own
stock which is something that only a few
weeks ago during the initial crash
corporations pledged never to do again
and I predict it on the show that they
would break that pledge within days and
here you have Herbalife breaking that
pledge to buy back their own stock
they're gonna issue junk bonds hundreds
of millions of dollars worth that
according to Jay Powell and his one
hundred and thirty trillion dollar
bazooka where he's gonna buy everything
and he's already started to buy junk
ETFs they will end up on the balance
sheet of the Fed which means that
American taxpayers will start getting
Herbalife products in the mail that they
will need to consume to keep the economy
from going bankrupt or to keep the Fed
from going bankrupt said the only thing
collateralizing the Federal Reserve Bank
within a few months will be Herbalife
products
and so it'll be a peach it'll be it'll
be a law will be passed that you must
accept in exchange let's save a tax
refund you won't get cash you'll get
herbal life products and you must
consume them or you're breaking the new
patriot act so the new Patriot Act will
be you must buy and consume Herbalife
products on behalf the Federal Reserve
Bank that just bailed out Herbalife a
Ponzi scheme
that's the placing of hedge funds and we
don't have an economy but we do have an
effective Ponzi scheme thank you signed
and this will be signed by Jay Powell
not Donald Trump you mean
Jay Jay pal signing it dynomite yes he's
guaranteeing good times for all and this
is trillions and trillions of dollars so
what's the future alike for these good
times
well assets on the balance sheets of the
four major central bank's approach
twenty trillion dollars for math
purposes if you were to count to one
trillion it would take you thirty one
thousand seven hundred and nine point
seven nine years
right so it's twenty trillion now in the
four major central banks right America's
guys between six and seven of that
trillion so yeah thirty percent thirty
three percent Japan is already one
hundred percent GDP on their balance
sheet the Bank of Japan so they've
pledged now to take that twenty trillion
to a global GDP number which would be
over a hundred trillion so they're
they're gonna boost the assets purchases
on their books by another four five
hundred percent so and then capitalism
as we know it and everything that's
happened in the West since the end of
World War two will be finished it'll all
be over if we all had thirty one
thousand seven hundred and nine years to
count to a trillion you know that's also
what Jeff Bezos is going to be worth
apparently in four years if you compound
at the same rate that Amazon shares have
been rising but you know in terms of
these good times back in 74 to 79 we did
have a really high inflation due to as
we've covered recently you know the 73
oil embargo the 73 to 74 oil embargo and
then
79 in the Iranian Revolution caused oil
prices to spike so we had those long
lines at the gas station odds and even
license plate numbers and that sort of
thing but you know today at that point
we still had manufacturing we had a lot
of assets to hollow out we had a private
equity hadn't started yet you know it
was another ten years away to start
hollowing out our economy and swapping
our assets for massive loads of debt so
at this point you know these good times
are going to in order to convince us
that there are some good times ahead and
they've got to keep on doing that
because remember that it's all
confidence games that's all any currency
is but especially fiat because you have
to have confidence that it's going to
mean something one day so the confidence
game to sustain this this hollowed out
economy we have where we're all trapped
in the house and no goods and services
are actually made in America anymore so
like I mean there's there's the the good
times it's gonna be weird to see how
much money actually does need to be
printed in order for us to believe we
have a good time it seems like the Robin
Hood app holders for example really
believe we're in good times because
there is super active at the moment for
example versus say on CNBC where you see
all these huge famous hedge fund guys
who are really saying this is the most
over mount valued market they've ever
seen like Druckenmiller recently said
that and he's one of the most famous
best investors ever and yet Robin Hood
app guys think like good times were in
JJ Powell's project and she's got our
back right well you know the old saying
is don't fight the Fed yes and that
strategy has been a winner
for 40 years so it's like doesn't make
any economic sense to buy into this
market except if the Fed is going to
take your back and and buy everything no
matter what at what any price now in
Venezuela they use the Bulevar is
confetti and so in America the dollar
will be used as confetti similarly it'll
be completely trashed to oblivion but
there'll be a black market so the
American black mark
it will explode in the next two or three
or five years and that most a commerce
will be happening person to person in
the shadows lawlessly effectively so
that's where the economy is moving
completely into the black market well
you know again good times that original
TV series happened in 74 to 79 at the
beginning of the petrodollar while the
petrodollar had started earlier this is
the this is where it was like tested its
strengths when we went off the gold
standard in 71 and here we only had oil
backing it and then the oil embargo
happened in the reigning revolution so
people were in doubt now we've come
full-circle to these good times at the
very end like that was the beginning
this is the end and in terms of how much
longer like this full circle we've come
pandemic could cost global economy
eighty-two trillion dollars in a
depression scenario of course to get to
82 trillion to count to 82 trillion we
take 2.6 million years which is kind of
halfway to the point it would take a
full circle from when humans first
emerged 2.6 million years ago to 2.6
million to in the future it's all ending
then yeah that's not just becoming a
black market really it's no one's gonna
pay any attention to the government at
all anymore anyway we're gonna take a
break when we come back much more coming
your way
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to go to Canada talk
to Marshall are back and despite the
fact that he's a perennial fan of the
perennial loser Toronto Maple Leafs we
still have him on this show occasionally
Marshall welcome back thanks max in
point of fact I'm in the the beautiful
city of New York right now so not in
Toronto at all I'm right in the belly of
the beast so to speak
you're a high-flying jet-setting
economist and deep thinker let's get
your thoughts on something here five
months in the pandemic the u.s. still
seems incapable of manufacturing basic
supplies like face masks what does this
tell you about our economy what needs to
change if anything Marshall it tells us
that we went way too far in favor of a
model where we said well that's offshore
as much manufacturing as possible and
retain the software onshore it's an
unviable model you can't be said to have
a serious first world economy when you
can't produce even the most basic of
medical needs for your citizenry so
hopefully that will induce a reached
rethink and and towards more
self-sufficiency we don't have to go all
the way towards total autarky but we
certainly need to rethink this go
globalization uber Hollis this is why we
have yann today because you you tweeted
something to the effect that if you
can't even manufacture basic supplies
like pharmaceuticals and masks you know
you have a serious economy you mentioned
autarky there you know this is a phrase
or a word that describes kind of a
self-contained economy doesn't like
France for example is more of an autarky
than any other country that I know of
but so to your point though the you know
if the country can't take care of itself
by basic manufacturing like a mask and
they've printed trillions and trillions
of dollars but they can't seem to get
masks out there it opens up you know
some serious questions about this
economy this American economy in other
countries and you know where you go well
how do you pursue your right I mean you
mentioned the trillions and trillions of
dollars we have no problem doing that
but you know the problem we have and
we've discussed this many times before
we have an overly fine
alized economy we emphasize
financialization we don't emphasize
producer ism so we've always taken the
view that somehow all you have to do is
keep the the printing presses going and
everything else will take care of itself
and that's clearly shown to be highly
deficient especially during this with
this crisis by contrast countries like
Germany which have retained viable
manufacturing systems have seemed to
have done a much better job in terms of
their response to the crisis and
likewise the economies of Asia you can
you can exclude China that's becoming
now very politically weighted but you
can look at countries like Taiwan South
Korea even Japan which has kept its
economy open for the entire time and has
also retained a viable manufacturing
system so I don't think there's any
coincidence that these are the countries
that have done the best during this
crisis I've created an index I call it
the macho bonehead index it seems like
countries that are run by macho
boneheads and let's put into this group
America Brazil and United Kingdom
to name three countries are doing this
coronavirus poorly some countries like
the ones you mentioned in Asia also New
Zealand are not run by necessarily I
don't think by macho boneheads and this
is coming at the end of the me2 movement
so you know maybe men you know after
losing horribly during the me2 movement
maybe man should just forget about
leadership roles I don't appear to be
doing anything right anymore Marshall I
remember christine lagarde once saying
that if Lehman Brothers have been called
laymen's sisters maybe the problems in
2008 wouldn't have been as bad I think
she meant that happen Jess but there's
something to be said for that if you
look at the people in in previous
financial crises that have offered the
best solutions they've generally been
women so in the Asian financial crisis
in 97-98 that that came on the heels of
a of a big derivatives disaster we you
had Brooksley born who was in heaven who
had then headed up the CFTC in the US
she wanted to regulate these instruments
and she was overruled by Rubin Greenspan
and summers the so-called committee to
save the world
likewise in 2008
could argue that the people that had the
best responses to this were people like
Sheila Bair at the FDIC and likewise
Elizabeth Warren who was would have been
inclined to been much more strict a bit
with the banking system and likewise
Christine broma who had the calls for
the most robust fiscal package which
would have really offset the loss but
one and a half trillion dollar hit to
GDP but we instead followed the advice
of people like summers you know who
seems to feature we're currently in
these policy because it he still seems
to have a major position of influence
and as far as democratic regimes go when
they print all this money and they print
charlington joins $1 some people are
saying you know what this is like MMT
the modern monetary theory or this is
like ubi universal basic income so
suddenly that was kind of pure read
during the run-up to the nomination here
in the u.s. of the democratic nominee
when that was suggested during the
debates but now it seems like we're
living in a world that's like mmt or ubi
what do you think certainly
operationally the whole idea there's
some sort of arbitrary financially can
financial constraint that's been blown
out the window and that was a key MNT
insight but you know you have to also to
give the M&T as a jew they also said
that it's not how much money it's what
you do with it that really matters and I
don't think any mmt or worth his or her
salt would argue that for the most part
these dollars have been deployed in
enhancing the economy's productive
capacity or indeed responding adequately
to the pandemic so in that sense it's a
bastardization of mmt what you've really
got is a lot of money being spun out or
the printing presses and used in the
furtherance of crony capitalism you know
there's something vaguely fascistic
about it it's it's more akin to
mussolini style fascism than it is to
what you would call an ideal M&T run
economy as you point out what we've seen
now is arbitrary financial printing
and what what would prevent folks on the
other side of this from asking well if
the money printing is arbitrary spurious
doesn't seem an any basis for why my
paying taxes what's the answer to that
the value of a fiat currency in many
respects is ultimately depends on the
credibility of our institutions and and
and that includes the taxing authority
and if you're not spending that money
correctly then you do risk undermining
the taxation authority of your federal
of the federal government and that in
turn does create real opposed a real
existential threat to a fiat currency so
it's a perfectly legitimate question to
be asking my preference all the way
through this crisis would have been
actions that in the first instance would
have gone to sustained relief more
effectively so I would have said
nationalizing payroll and and per-capita
distributions to the states rather than
creating all these newfangled programs
with minimal oversight and discretion
and and and get it to the people so that
at least you create a floor on the
economy that the problem you have right
now is that you have a man a government
mandated shutdown and you're telling if
you want to stay home and to not work
and not not a heard of paycheck but
you're not giving them the means to
sustain that that lockdown politically
and this is a real problem and I think
it does create a an almost revolutionary
fervor in the country but it's not good
if it's not handled correctly this is
apply to Canada I mean we always talk
about different they know the global
situation and the u.s. situation numbers
assuming that since you are Canadian
live in Canada most the time what is
this what's going on accounting it kind
of a somebody catch Canada's actually
had a pretty good crisis I mean first of
all the the number of deaths has been I
think it's under six thousand and most
of that has been in Ontario and Quebec
and largely very tragically it's been in
nursing homes but I'd say that's been
over 60 percent of the of the death so
you know if you look at a place like
British Columbia there's been less than
60 fatalities about the last time I
looked they have implemented many of the
same as the US but the relief provisions
have been far more generous so therefore
they've been able to
much greater political support for them
and there's been much less cronyism in
involved you know the in in general the
program's themselves have been
administered well it's taken most people
anywhere from seven to ten days to get
their money so you don't have this
ridiculous situation where people are
waiting you know literally months to get
a a beta of a vital paycheck or a vital
support payment from the government to
in order to survive and the as a result
the the caseloads have come down are the
fatalities have remained loan and now
the government is slowly and steadily
reopening the economy again and that I
think they will do so with considerably
less damage going forward than the
United States which is I think had one
of the most dysfunctional responses with
any government around the world
you know Canada's war on you could say
the socialist side of the political
spectrum and it's got more government
direct contact with people we see that
in their health system etc so to get the
checks to people it was easier task in
the United States the checks went to the
banks first and then they told the banks
Oh distributed to people but then the
banks just held on to the money as they
always do and the people didn't get
anything particularly in the small
business world so this is kind of
another interesting contrast between two
political systems and this Kovan
nineteen seems to show Canada's system
to be slightly more effective impactful
Marshall yeah I think that's right look
you you use the banking system in the
way that the US has done it and
naturally it's gonna buy a bias towards
people that have pre-existing banking
relationships with the entities
concerned so of course if you're a
medium or large like business that does
a lot of banking with Bank of America or
Wells Fargo you're in a much more
advantageous position than a small
business that has maybe 50 employees and
that's why as I said earlier
nationalizing payroll and doing per
capita revenue distributions to the the
states would have been a much more
equitable program because you wouldn't
have to reinvent the wheel you would
have a situation where for example the
states you you have the federal
government crediting the bank accounts
of the states the states can go ahead
and then keep sustaining the pro
they're doing to handle the pandemic and
also to maintain relief there is no
reason to set up all these new programs
so what's actually happened is that
you've had the same thing that happened
in 2008 there's been massive political
favoritism it's happened under the cover
of a national pandemic but it's
exacerbated many pre-existing inequities
that were already evident in the u.s.
system now apparently the four major
central banks in the world now 20
trillion in assets they've bought in the
last couple of years they've stated
their goal is to take that up to a
hundred trillion and I mean from my
observation as a Wall Street veteran I
would say this looks like the few
players are taking the world's economy
private in a leveraged buyout by
printing their own money and we're gonna
end up with feudalism what do you think
of that I think we are on the way
towards feudalism we already have a
feudal system in many respects I mean
you you look at our essential the way we
distribute food for example we have
these highly concentrated number of meat
processors that seem to depend on serf
labor in cooperate in inadequately
protected conditions which is why many
of these processing plants became
hotspots for the virus likewise you know
we depend on undocumented immigrants
coming in from Central America to pick
the the fruit and vegetables because
again we refuse to pay a living wage to
Americans to do it and you know as I've
joking they have said to people in the
past you know I thought the civil war
was fought in in part to get rid of
slavery but we we seem to have
reconstituted that in this country in a
different form Bravo
well martial law back thanks again for
being on the kaisers report and that's
gonna do it for this edition of the cons
report with me max Kaiser anesthesia her
but like to think I guess Marshall are
back you can follow him on Twitter I do
this guy's got the dope if you like to
get in touch with us it's Kaiser report
on Twitter until next time bye y'all
[Music]